[Music]
combat talk with the king
now that the weigh-in is here
rolling in tank is about to get it done
king is on vacay
it's feeling kind of good yo
my thing is right we all know that
tank's supposed to win
right conventional wisdom says that
to do with the most success the a side
to do with the perceived better skills
the guy that's been boxing since he was
seven years old compared to the guy
that's been boxing since he was 17 years
old she won this fight
i don't know
then then then
little me this batman
why the hell did i bet on rolly
for the knockout
why the hell did i bet on rolly for the
win
i don't know man
something about this smell a little bit
different
feels a little bit different tanky looks
a lot relaxed
rolly looks like he's ready
um
and he's been consistent in his message
his message is he's going to go in there
knock tank out
is this probably the biggest punch that
tank has fought yeah
kid is young he's hungry biggest puncher
technically sound he's not the greatest
technically sound person but the last
person we said that about was
deontay wilder
not technically sound at all
uh 100
a puncher
started late in life
but achieve this goals when you have
belief in yourself yeah you can get
knocked down but you can get up
and put in work so
i think this fight is going to be
explosive
i think
rowley
is going to bring something very
different something very dynamic
to this fight
something very unpredictable
and um
is tank ready for that
does tank actually want that
the tank truck train hard enough for
this
you know there's a lot of questions man
so you know tank's supposed to win you
know
but
i'm going for the upset i want something
nice in boxing i want something fun i
want something to talk about
i'm going for rolly
and five
it's combat talk with the king yo see
you next week when we got some dope
popping off i just had to leave you
something something for people to just
you know check it out or whatever um
yo
this is gonna be crazy dope
and uh i'll see y'all next week
right now we are finding a beach
i ain't gonna put up the beverage of
choice to drink right now because
they're not sponsoring me
sponsor me so then
i'll
post your drink
let's go
combat talk with the king see y'all next
week thanks
[Applause]
[Music]